walk
around you move your sword too
much
this the sword on the center
line so for example on the first move
slow you go over here like
that
slower sw's on the center line and I
move my body
up
again in correct Bo
over on the
center
up move me and on my you see between my
hands you guys see that and put marker
here you can see make a knife in hand
with your right hand put it aiming at my
spine you see my
spine there you to this is where I lift
up okay put it back
on I don't want this over here you see
where touch my body come forward with
your hand just come forward you see it's
on the side you see that it's
incorrect over here for forward right on
my spine
okay you go boom straight up my
body boom he
goes look where my hand
is pay
attention okay if we lift all this and
you push straight forward just right on
my
spine okay we're down here
okay he starts to go I
follow okay when I come out here to the
it's got to be on the Y Line I'm going
to make it go this way so I have to go
to the edge of my outer rim and then I
make it go okay so my elbows with my
shoulder and as he goes forward where do
you think it's going to go again here on
that middle line right on my middle line
comes around move me where is it on the
top of my head on the middle of my head
War comes down and cracks okay again
where is it right here on my Center Line
right here he
goes boom comes in again where am I we
come up and he extends right on my
Center Line okay over here he comes up I
bring the hand
up you see right on my Center Line he
goes keep going okay SK it's all my prob
center of my
head
in right here right on my Center
l for
[Music]
thank
see the two sides are not doing the same
thing he has a
shorter Foster weapon on the inside so
he's trying to get to the
inside the Joe is slower except at the
distal end so I try to stay at the
distal end of my weapon I don't work mid
Joe that would that's what he's trying
to do is get to Mid Joo and in so I have
move so that we hang out at the dist
land of my
weapon and then I have the benefit of
having a slightly longer
weapon so as I as I go to ski this move
has to now come out
here don't want
you
see even here where he missed that's not
that's not enough Advantage I want to be
out where I have those extra let's look
again what do you want to call
that 6 in okay 6 in past this sword what
do you say you laugh it's like 10 10
okay 10 we'll call it 10 that's that's
where I want to hang out and
like it's not every day I get to say hey
little dude back the up that's what
I'm doing this a little weapon stay out
okay I'm playing the tall guys game okay
so as we go look I'm out
here you see and now now now I have the
advantage again so here's where I'm
doing everything we come in he's trying
to close again go ahead you see he's
trying to close it again if you pay
attention and I put my weapon where he
is he's at Mid J you see that no I go
back out to where my weapon is there's
your eight 10 Ines you see boom you
still going to hit his wrist can you
guys see that walk around so you can see
it I still hit him okay then I come up
and I try to poke him with the
tip don't come
in while you're seeing like that I I
don't need to do that I hit him with the
tip
[Music]
boom do I have to penetrate the target
yes but don't over penetrate to
Mido so I go here like this and I'm here
like this you see
this you see this no that's not going to
fly then stay there please okay and then
you can see I'm at Mid Joe how I
penetrated back on the circle back
out back on the circle back out got it
usually it's just lazy you're going that
way say you take little baby
steps you have to do what you about to
do
boom boom boom back out
boom or you're too
linear it's hard to make up distance
when you're trying trying to get back
out from having gone in
forward so you don't do that you spir
rotate to fire so as I'm going I'm going
this
way you see that and that's how I don't
have to take as big a step to be just
the tip just the tips working okay I try
to go back as hard you get these little
steps go on the circle and now you have
it
okay just a tip right there on his arm
Bo
boom try to notice how I'm keeping them
out
long okay try
it okay
relatedly your booking is not going back
and trying to stay out here remember is
trying to go
in okay so watch all the places that I'm
moving look how I moved
in on the Y there I come in then I
and coming
forward forward go back where you are
and don't take the last
step look where my foot
is not out
here
okay right in okay got it you guys
understand this is where you're trying
to be stick your weapon out like you did
ski
where am I Mido see Mido not out
here I'm trying to get to Mid Joo
because his dual lever weapon is not
move at Mid
Joo okay and that's where I'm trying to
get mid Joo get to Mid Joo inside his
weapon he
goes he goes back back out I'm not at
Mid Jo you see he
goes
okay good draw I start to follow back
okay I'm not going to move this
foot he goes to
ski look at where I got you see and I'm
trying to cut his head off with mid buen
when I do
this this deviation can now happen but
it doesn't only
happen go to SK and I do this you see
that I'm try to always get into
him this is where I want to
be okay he goes again he has to get way
the F out there that's kind of too much
for work he goes Bo and I'm trying to do
the same thing that's right now I'm
going to yumii okay look where his mid
Joo is and I'm going to try and get
inside of the midj on the back side of
the weapon
now so careful with your y yels on the
back foot you're out of range boom out
of
range okay you're trying to get inside
his weapon
in here boom in okay try it again